what is the objective of the game was to
stare down to Nexus like I'd like I was
gonna go to win no you meant like like
how do you where you got what are the
two colors representing each one booth
what's the currency of the game gold
name all the positions mid top ATC Kari
support jungler name any summoner spell
um oh my gosh um we got him
no no no you did not get me oh well I
know the alts I don't like on spell um
oh hey you put them on f or like D think
about it Oh flash oh yeah teleport TV
flash um
yeah he'll like yeah name five champions
any champion oh um Lou solution which is
Keith's favorite um
anivia which is froggen favorite um geez
lissandra which is another favorite jinx
um
do I dare say Teemo you said yes auntie
mo I like it going but wait Swain
various yeah dari
name any item oh I think I buy these
swords i buy these spells and I get
wards I got a ton of things what's the
name of the giant purple worm Oh Baron
yeah like this elder dragon now his
mountain is earth was finally like I
yeah
you